you enjoy doing I guess in inning when
you call these chat shows right sure we
have a chat
yeah a chat chat show and their talk
show Street America have you done a lot
of these chat shows I've done a few of
them they were they do feel like a blind
date a little bit right you're kind of I
mean I was kind of you were kind of
pimped out to me by your producer and
this like trying to kind of sold me and
to like to you and kind of like we've
set up on this kind of blind date
situate the term pimped out I don't
think I don't think that's the right
approach I like to think that you saw me
somewhere maybe you were in an airport
and I saw a screen and you saw me and
you were like I must be with that man
it was white right yes yes I did I did
find out so you're I know a few things
about you yes you are your middle name
is Christopher yes you were born on
April 18th he's just in a week so happy
birthday thank you that means we're both
Aries yes Aries was a date we just
talked about that what why is it not a
date let's just say it's a date I don't
mean to sound creepy but you're married
please though say something here this
water is delicious all right is this
your shop around no this is his way of
saying it's not a date I was doing great
I was spent and then she brings up the
wife when I gotta call her
was day no no it's fine I'll talk to her
since she doesn't watch the show anyway
she's really not a fan now you do have
in real life we cannot be together
because you I'm married and you have a
boyfriend is that right oh my god I know
that was gonna be brought up yes I do
I do yeah and I I met him when he was
four but is that true he was just coming
out of diapers when I first met him yeah
is this a real thing yeah this was a
long time ago right still four I thought
you met him like now he's six and it's
okay now we can speak back to me so it's
fine no show you were renting I think
you were you were 10 years old school
together I had this idea that my
twenties like I would go and you know
date kind of exotic different kinds of
people and then it's just come full
circle I'm effectively dating my
neighbor like you've known him forever
does it does it change anything you must
be kind of nice you've known each other
that long yeah yeah I mean we lives took
different directions for a while it
wasn't like I saw him through the
awkward phase of puberty or anything
like that I think I might as a
fully-formed out my puberty lasted 26
years even a joke look at me now yeah
look at me now can be taken two ways
what a woman says look at you now or a
look at you now yeah it's a winter
predation
you